[Music]
chuck
yes you might remember early math you
should have learned this in middle
school but maybe
philadelphia public school please
exclusively let's not assume anything
deal
let's not jump to any conclusions
all right
so
so base 10 we use base 10 because we
have 10 fingers 10
digits as a finger is a digit right and
so
um and what we say is we have we go one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
but what we're really doing
is we're starting at zero
that's what we're really doing
and we go zero one two three four five
six seven eight nine
right how many numerals is that that's
ten ten
that is why we know we are in base 10.
okay
when you're in base 10 you have 10
numerals
and when it's time
to go into the next round because you've
exhausted all your numerals you now
start having to combine them
okay
so you go from zero one two three four
seconds every nine
now we gotta use a new slot
the tens place
okay
the tenth place we stick a one there and
we start this exercise all over again
with a zero okay so the number that
comes after nine is one zero and we call
that ten yes but it's actually numeral
11.
oh my gosh
what is happening
no 10 is 11.
well you know
the first person to get tracked to get a
disease or something they call that what
patient zero patients they're really
patient one the first one but right
patient zero sounds more mysterious and
cooler it does you know it's totally uh
so
so anyhow we go to one zero one one one
two one three up to
one nine
and now we ran out of
numbers we can make starting with a one
okay so now we start with a two
and then we go two zero two one two two
two up to two nine you take this up to
nine nine
at this point we have exhausted every
possible combination
of a zero through nine
okay just think about it if take any
pair of those numbers put them in any
order we move past it on the way up to
99. okay what happened when you run out
of all your combinations you go to one
zero zero then one zero one you just
start that all over again right right
one and then you're up to one nine nine
and then you gotta go to two
two zero zero and then you go up to
three and four and five then you finally
get up to what
nine ninety nine nine 9.99
with 9.99 you have used every possible
combination of three
digits
and you have also put yourself in a
position where you can say our prices
are insane
[Laughter]
so you ran out if you're going to keep
counting you got to add another slot
okay so now we have one zero zero
zero
okay and you keep going up so that's how
we we take it for granted but that's how
we count in base ten
okay
if we were to count in another base
like base five
okay
okay
sounds convoluted oh by the way let me
make it clear to you there is no numeral
that is the numeral
10. that's right
think about that okay
right the 10 is how many
numerals we put together 4 base 10 but
there's no numeral 10. we have to
construct it from the pre-existing
numerals okay all right so now base five
we go
zero one two three four
okay now what
we're done
you gotta go to the next slot okay
okay
you're done
okay
we went from zero to nine and we were
done okay we went zero to win base five
now we we laid out all five numerals
zero one two three four and four okay
what do we do next
i don't know i guess we gotta go you
gotta start a new slot let's start a new
slot so it's now it's one zero zero
one one two one two two one
sorry and i mean no disrespect to base
five i think five is a lovely number but
this sucks
no so but let's keep going right right
okay so so now it's two zero two one two
three two four two four
three zero three one three two three
three three four four zero four one two
three
four four
now what
oh my gosh
what do i do next where do i go what
will i do
okay you can't count higher than 44.
until you introduce another slot
well then what is that now one zero zero
in base five at one zero two one zero
three one zero four
[Music]
one one zero one one zero one one one
one two why would you ever do this
okay so
okay so watch right now that we have the
hang of this
let's use base two
okay foundation of computing
okay binary code binary code
with base two you have two numerals
what are they
zero and one okay so let's count
together chuck are you ready okay
zero
one one you just ran out
next number
zero no
zero one what's the next number one no
zero one
you bring in the next slot
oh okay
zero zero one no
zero zero
one now you know you got this slot you
put a one there
right that's what i said it was one zero
that's not what you said okay i did that
is so not what you said i did run
what's next well you gotta go zero one
no no oh no one one one one white one
one zero no no no
no i'm looking forward i'm sorry now
it's one one start again okay start
again okay here we go see my problem is
i'm just seeing i keep going forward
forward okay okay starting again zero
zero and one one now you're done one and
zero correct and then
one and one correct now you ran out what
do you have now we're done we're done
what's next
that'd be zero nope one zero zero a one
zero oh okay you can okay so you just
gotta keep you can keep going you keep
just going going you keep
next after one one one
oh my god now i'm trying to think one
one one that's nine nine nine
so now we need the next slot yes
which would be
wait oh god this is so confusing
it's the next slide zero no it's just a
one oh no it's another one with uh
always go
right it's one zero zero zero zero
that's what
correct so let's keep going
one zero zero zero one zero
zero one
one zero one zero
one zero one one one
one one zero zero
there it is okay because now we got the
four ones exactly that's
that's
9999 well no that's it doesn't equal
that but that's just that's
the same you're in the same situation
right okay okay that's it and this just
keeps going jesus just keep going the
difference is go ahead what's the point
the difference is now every slot
you multiply by a factor of two for how
many total
uh things it can count rather than by a
factor of ten
okay it's by fact by a power of two
so early generation computers uh you had
they the the storage was in kilobytes
right right kilobytes and how many is a
kilo
a thousand thousand okay but it's not so
we would say that but it was not really
a thousand bytes it was two to the tenth
bytes
okay so i do two to the tenth power here
and it's a thousand and twenty four oh
one twenty four okay okay and
twenty-four so if you have two times two
times two times two you keep doing that
ten times you get to a thousand twenty
four twenty four okay
so
i'm saying this binary way of counting
and calculating has great value
in a computer because the computer just
has to be on or off or it's a yes or no
or it's this way or that way and that
binarity
it's great for algorithms yes it makes
it great for everything a computer wants
and needs to do right so
if we get a signal from
aliens
and
its numbers in base 10 we should be
suspect of it
because like why would they use base 10
right now we know that they don't have
10 fingers
whatever got they got all right but if
it's in base two
it's like oh
okay okay right if they got base two
it's just like steve jobs is also their
god
he's the god of all he's the god of all
computer beings
so anyhow that's a long long 10 minutes
there just telling you how to count in
base two so let me hear let me just hear
you run off some counting in base two go
all right so it's zero one
and then it's one zero and then it's one
one
and then it's
nine hundred and nine
i have failed oh my god
[Laughter]
i don't blame you i blame me for this
oh my god you sound like my mom
all right
every good teacher says that i don't
blame you i play myself it's zero one
one zero one one one zero zero one zero
one one one zero one one one one zero
zero zero zero
one no one zero zero zero one zero zero
one what okay now with my kids i had
them counting base two
when i walked them to school each day
just to get and counting on other bases
just so they can free their minds
of the this prison of base 10 because
it's just an artifact of having 10
fingers and there's nothing deeper
magical about it
well your kids must have hated you
come on kids let's walk to school
[Laughter]
where's mommy is she available
no
uh their mother was not an escape from
this because she has a phd in
mathematical physics so
yeah they there's no escaping that all
right chuck that's what we have time for
you
you get a c plus on this
one i don't blame you i don't blame me
[Laughter]
all right there's been another
wacky star talk explainer video chuck
always good to have you always a
pleasure neil degrasse tyson keep
looking up
[Music]
you